How close to you,
'cause we were talking about the hair, is Russian Doll?
Can you talk to us about this show,
that is so well respected,
so well loved, critically received, nominations?
Yeah.
What do you think it is as the creator of it?
Thanks Drew, oh, so just, thank you.
It's true.
Yeah, it's an interesting thing.
I mean I'm always very moved
that they even give us the money
to go investigate these big questions.
There's this Viktor Frankl book called-
Man's Search for Meaning?
Man's Search for meaning.
That's my favorite book!
Yeah, so I remember I bringing that
into the the writer's room on the first day
of the first days and then saying like,
"All right, so this but half hour comedy."
(audience laughs)
But I guess the stuff that I draw on
is almost more parable or sort of life experience
or almost like spiritual experience in a way.
It's oddly almost a theological show,
except by way of science as opposed to theory.
And I'm so curious about things,
namely the first season is really asking the question,
"How do I stop dying?"
And the second season is really asking the question,
"How do I go about living?"
See, that is so cool.
Yeah (chuckles).
How do I go about dying?
How do I go about living?
Yeah, so, I was really curious about that.
So you can read these books.
You go to the yoga classes and you hear about Ram Dass,
and you go to the shrink and they tell you,
"Just be here now."
And the thinking feeling person really says, "But how?"
Yeah.
I was like, "Oh my gosh now we can actually...
Explore that.
Let's dig into those questions
and see what we find.
Well, I think now I know why it's such a success.
And I just love you for exploring those subjects
and for your honesty and your journey
and your curiosity
as you so brilliantly put, that's so apt.
And I'm just so happy and excited
for the success of whether it's the Orange is the New Black,
and your life, and the show.
I'm so happy for you.
And I'm so excited for season two.
How do we start living?
I love that question.
It's so profound.
(audience claps)
It really is.
And I'm ready to!
I'm ready too!
I'm ready baby!
I'm already living.
All these new ways, I love getting older.
By the way growing up
is not overrated.
My God, it's the greatest.
Oh my God.
Is it not the best?
What a...
What a false bill of goods.
They're like, "Oh, well, be careful."
It's the best up here.
I completely agree!
Yeah, I know!
I only get better and better.
It was such an idiot back then.
I had fun.
Yeah, it was fun.
It was fun.
Sometimes, sometimes.
Not everybody's idea of fun.
Yeah!
I had a great time.
Yeah.
I don't regret a thing.
But God I love growing up
and getting older.
Ah, I love it.
Do you know, what's a real sign for me of getting older too?
My perfect afternoon or evening
is hanging out either with friends
or by myself.
Yeah.
But with my kids, I've always got the crossword with me.
Ooh, are you
And I heard
a big crossword?
you're a crossworder!
That's my whole life.
I love the crossword!
All I care about the cross, ah!
I built one for the New York Times.
You built a crossword?
I built with
a wonderful woman, Deb Amlen.
We built it together.
Yeah, it was incredible.
You should make a crossword.
I would love to make a crossword.
Yeah.
And I'm very excited
'cause I'm gonna work with this guy, Matt Gaffney
who does the Week Magazine and the New Yorker.
And he's doing a crossword for our next issue
of a magazine I started called Drew.
It has my name on it, ugh.
But the content sounds terrific
But he's gonna do the crossword.
It's like meeting your Marvel superhero.
Yeah.
It's like Thor's in the other room
and you get to meet him.
Yeah.
But will you do a crossword with me?
Ah, this would be a dream.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪